Bonjour à toutes et à tous !
Je vous présente Ephippium et Pitanga,
de la famille des brachycéphales.
Ces minuscules grenouilles sont brésiliennes,
oranges et toxiques.
Et comme si elles
débarquaient des années 80,
elles adorent porter du fluo.
Cette histoire de
grenouilles fluo commence par une étude sur le son.
Une équipe de recherche
internationale menée par une bio acousticienne
spécialiste de l'évolution,
s'est intéressée aux chants
de celles que l'on surnomme les grenouilles citrouille.
Durant la saison des amours
on peut les apercevoir de jour, à la
recherche d'un partenaire.
et si on tend l'oreille on peut entendre ce son :
Hé non,  il ne s'agit pas du son d'un criquet,
mais bien du chant des grenouilles
citrouilles.
En étudiant la structure de l'oreille d'Ephippium et Pitanga,
l'équipe de recherche a découvert...
qu'elles sont sourdes à leur propre chant.
Coâ?
Pourtant ça demande un sacré effort
de produire un son.
Sans compter
que ça attire les prédateurs
et d'un point de vue évolution, ça pose pas mal de questions.
A quoi tu sers, Pourquoi t'es là ?
Bien décidés à comprendre comment ces mini grenouilles communiquent entre elles
et à découvrir leurs techniques de drague...
les scientifiques sont partis à la recherche
de signaux visuels qu'elle
pourraient utiliser.
Qu'est ce que t'espères ?
Oui, parce-qu'il
se trouve que ces espèces sont justement connues
pour utiliser des signes et des
mouvements de bouche
en période de reproduction.
Un genre de langue des signes de grenouille.
Hey, how are you doing ?
A la recherche de
motifs sur la peau des grenouilles,
la scientifique et ses collègues du
Muséum d'Histoire Naturelle
les ont éclairées avec une lampe UV.
Et là...Waowww..
Les grenouilles se sont illuminées.
Face à un tel mystère de l'évolution, la bioacousticienne a alors réuni autour d'elle
une équipe pluridisciplinaire et
internationale
pour étudier cette fluorescence.
D'un côté des experts de
la reconstruction et de l'imagerie des os,
de l'autre des physiciens,
des spécialistes de l'imagerie pour l'étude des matériaux anciens,
mais aussi des biologistes, des chimistes et des paléontologues.
Car ce que vous voyez sur ces images ça n'est pas la fluorescence
provenant de la peau,
mais celle générée par les os des grenouilles,
qui absorbent les ultraviolets
et émettent une lumière que l'on voit à travers la peau.
Une telle intensité de fluorescence des os n'a été observée
chez aucun autre animal jusqu'à présent.
En utilisant des
techniques d'imagerie développées
pour l'étude des matériaux anciens,
les chercheurs ont comparé la fluorescence
de différentes grenouilles.
Ici, Ephippium, Pitanga et leur cousine
sous lumière naturelle,
puis sous une lampe UV.
En ne sélectionnant que la lumière issue de la fluorescence
les chercheurs ont montré que les motifs
qui apparaissent sont en fait créés
par des tissus osseux inhabituels.
Le squelette tout entier est fluorescent,
mais au niveau du crâne et du dos,
les grenouilles citrouille possèdent
ce que l'on appelle des plaques osseuses.
En fait, c'est la peau elle même qui s'ossifie.
Qui s'ossifie  ?
C'est la peau elle-même qui devient de l'os,
et c'est ce qui fait apparaître les motifs,
visibles à l'oeil nu.
Les scientifiques étudient actuellement
les origines du phénomène :
Est-ce une molécule particulière
qui serait présente dans les os,
ou est-ce la structure de l'os lui même ?
Mais surtout il reste une question que l'on se pose tous :
A quoi ça sert ?
Car rien ne dit que cette fluorescence ait une fonction.
Elle pourrait peut-être permettre aux grenouilles
de mieux repérer leurs partenaires.
Sauf que le phénomène est spectaculaire
quand on observe Pitanga dans le noir, éclairée par une lampe UV.
Mais de jour, la quantité d'UV est
beaucoup plus faible
et la fluorescence est masquée par la lumière ambiante.
Des travaux complémentaires
sur le comportement des grenouilles et leurs capacités visuelles
permettront d'y voir plus clair...
Certains oiseaux et araignées
ont la capacité de voir des motifs fluorescents,
même illuminés par la lumière du jour.
Des prédateurs, en quête d'un petit snack,
pourraient ainsi être alertés
sur la toxicité de ces grenouilles orange.
Pour résumer, nous avons de minuscules grenouilles toxiques
qui sont sourdes à leur propre chant,
qui communiquent en langue des signes,
qui ont des os fluorescents,
et une peau super fine et orange.
Donc,  si comme moi vous pensez qu'on a trouvé
le premier x-men, qui est une x grenouille,
n'hésitez pas à partager cette vidéo,
commenter, aimer,
et puis, ben  je suis désolée j'ai pas trouvé d'chute, déso.
Déso fluo.Des os fluo.
Et surtout,
n'oublie pas de t'abonner !
Qui s'ossifie, qui se saucifie.